piele y Diego Armando Maradona
mantuvieron una relación con vaivenes
durante décadas protagonizaron una
eterna puja por apropiarse el título de
mejor jugador de todos los tiempos cada
uno con estilos distintos el argentino
siendo más creativo y el brasileño más
contundente en el área
los astros se dispararon con municiones
pesadas inclusive del ámbito personal
tiene dignidad para hablar de mí
primero que se fije en lo de él personal
que lo tiene y muy
muy cuando hablo cuando hablo
es familiar Así que que no me
joda
en el aspecto deportivo ambos buscaron
menospreciarse mutuamente con ironías al
brasileño puso Maradona por debajo de
Alfredo y Stefano Mientras que el
argentino descreyó de los mil goles de
Pelé y remarcó que verlo jugar era
aburrido
sin embargo el tiempo los acercó en una
relación de respeto y amistad
en los últimos años ambos reconocieron
la grandeza y la importancia que
tuvieron para la historia del fútbol y
dejaron de lado sus disputas dialécticas
teléfono de los personajes que mayor
respeto demostró cuando Maradona
falleció despidiéndolo con un cálido
mensaje en sus redes sociales
Qué triste noticia perdía un gran amigo
y el mundo perdió una leyenda Aunque era
mucho por decir pero por ahora que Dios
le dé fortaleza a la familia Un día
espero que podamos jugar a la pelota
juntos en el cielo
tras una relación de amor y odio Pelé
Maradona dejaron inconclusa su disputa Y
decidieron compartir el trono del fútbol
mundial